the Joe Rogan experience I am very
curious now that this Jala Maxwell guy
or lady got arrested
you know the Jeffrey Epstein's yeah
confidant what what first of all how
quick before they kill her second of all
if they don't kill her what is she gonna
say and who's going down cuz there's a
lot of people going down is it's pretty
bonkers i watch that the election you
think he had affect the other 100
percent 100 percent yeah as i said well
first of all Trump used to hang out with
that guy this picture with Melania and
Trump and Jeffrey Epstein and ghilane
and Fox News cut out Trump they cut the
edited the picture so the Trump wasn't
in the picture in there like well we
made a mistake like that she didn't make
a mistake there's the picture they were
posing partying together they hung out
what I know at the end of the the
dot-com on Netflix they said that he had
all of those tapes and all of those
rooms were being taped so I wonder if
she has access to that or that they
burned that that's a good question
what's up yeah you know he got a picture
of Bill Clinton in a dress in the 4a of
his house
damn it's a crazy picture like you are
my [ __ ] because he had Clinton flew
with him like 26 times look at that
that's a picture that's a real picture
that was in the foyer of his house how
crazy is that that's a real picture man
my friend Eric Weinstein I've seen that
picture in real life that's a real
painting a painting yeah not a photo
painting sorry oh but he also he made it
tonton he made him made it to let him
know [ __ ] I own you look we're friends
and then you came on my house and I got
a painting hey Hannibal I want to show
you something is you and address if you
and I have been partying together and I
flew you to some Island and we [ __ ]
kids together
and then you came on my house and
there's a painting you in a dress you
believe what have I done
yeah just set us all on fire I don't
deserve to live anymore anyway it's I
actions it's so crazy because it's one
of those things where you would hear
about that from like the craziest
conspiracy theorists like bro
there's an island they take all these
elites and they have these underage
girls on this island you like get the
[ __ ] out of here with this crazy talk
that is so that's crazy talk and then
you find out wait it's true
and they had scientists there and
lawyers there and politicians there like
what there really was an island like
they had the Prince what's-his-name
Prince Andrew Prince Andrew was there
his his part was it was funny cuz they
say no it's this picture of you yeah
that is a picture of me but I don't
remember yeah he was like I don't hug
I'm a royal Royals don't hug he just
kept it yeah that's me but I don't I
don't know what you yeah he's this blank
face lie like that and just keep it you
know just keep it news or what it is
what it is well why did you see that
interview that he did the full interview
I just saw in the doc well I there's an
interview with him I forget who the
woman was it was interviewing them but
when you're watching the interview you
like holy Sh
why did you do this like you know that
you're guilty and you agreed to do this
interview like this isn't even the cops
this is like a reporter and you're
talking to this reporter and you're
clearly full of [ __ ] and really nervous
this is great the whole thing's crazy is
old money white guy confidence but it's
also its royal confidence right they
have they have real well they also have
crazy libel laws in the UK like they can
get away with a lot over there because
like they could sue you for all kinds of
[ __ ] and the royal family I'm Shores
extremely litigious this is a whole
stories here it is
jillaine Maxwell as allegedly secret
video footage
of Prince Andrew oh Jesus pornhub here
we come
it just seems like we're gonna movie man
it's like the the movie just keeps
getting crazier and crazier
[Applause]